okay first of all two incredible
performances both so emotional lots of
announcements tonight a lot of things
first of all are you gonna have to go to
therapy after this night because those
performances had me choked up I was able
to do those performances because I go to
therapy there you go so that's the truth
I like that
congratulations to you thank you so much
we're so blessed and so happy so just to
announce on a show where it's family you
know it's I grew up on the show and now
to announce that I'm having kids on the
show it's just like truly a full circle
moment so it was beautiful are there any
limitations when you're pregnant
thinking into like the finale night of
things you just don't want to do
yeah lifts are gonna be probably a no-go
uh just right because I'm not throwing
you up we are not doing any of that we
are protecting that little guy I'm
saying probably but
I think just overall just the safety of
the baby and you know what we don't
really need all of that I think Wayne is
a great dancer and performer that we're
just gonna we're gonna dance our
ourselves away in the freestyle we don't
need any tricks I like that I like that
what are you thinking for the finale it
is a big moment for you
I think it's just
it's so big that my my thing is just to
have the best time ever and whatever
happens under that umbrella that's what
we'll do I'll leave that up to Whitney
the freestyle them like Whitney do your
thing let's go let's let's go yeah so as
long as I just don't have the best time
ever because if I've said said to some
other people it's just a rule right in
general if you have a good time if an
audience sees you doing your thing
they're like oh I want to do what you're
doing if they see you going oh this is
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life then they're not so invested you
know so let's have a blast the three of
us yes the three of you saying goodbye
to Lynn any words you want to say
yeah I mean Glenn you are amazing you
are a legend I mean in the ballroom
world there's nobody like you and so the
fact that you've done this show and have
watched me on this show for so long for
over 10 years and I've known you for 10
years I just want to say how grateful I
am for your encouragement and critiques
and I hope that you find everything that
you're looking for after this
I'm a I'm a fan of lens just as because
I've watched the show and before I I
loved his critiques and his energy and
and it's so nice to see someone that
truly loves the art of the thing that
they talk about and judge so when they
judge you it's not with with uh Venom or
spite or I'll show you especially
talking to the celebrities it's more
about I love this thing and I want you
to so I'm Gonna Give You true words of
advice and it's like taking love from
your grandpa so of course we're gonna
miss him and I'm happy that I got to be
on this last season with him yeah thank
you guys and good luck next week thank
you